they keep on coming more than 400 10,000
refugees from Myanmar have already
crossed the border into Bangladesh and
no one knows how many will still arrive
in the camps the situation is already at
a breaking point food water shelter
everything is scarce here many of the
eight deliveries are organized by
private Bangladeshi citizens if we do
not help the government of Bangladesh
this problem will be difficult to solve
the refugees are getting increasingly
desperate in distributing the aid to
those who really need it can't be done
from the back of a truck some 40
kilometers north lies the hospital of
Cox's Bazar the district capital here
doctors are treating around 30 Rohingya
refugees with severe injuries they have
sustained burns broken limbs and gunshot
wounds the hospital only has 250 beds
and was already overstretched before the
refugees arrived and this influx due to
the orchid se termina has been a great
burden to us because these patients are
huge in number diversity injuries
difficult to manage injuries some
infected cases old cases are coming so
with the existing resources existing
medicine existing manpower it's
certainly difficult for us to deal with
this influx outside the hospital locals
voiced their resentment towards the
Rohingya refugees because of the row
hinge ER our country is suffering
greatly many of them break the law they
steal they rob us and the women workers
prostitutes collective of state we don't
know hospital here is a tip 85% or 90%
Rohingya here so we don't get the
service here
we tell you go the other other service
center you don't get them
we have local people don't get the
service in our country back in the camps
Bangladeshi authorities are trying to
manage the chaos the government has
designated an area to house 400,000
refugees where aid can be properly
distributed but with hunger and illness
spreading it's a race against time